I have to ask just back to Jiu-Jitsu for
a little bit what's your favorite
submission now that you've been doing it
what's uh how do you like to submit your
opponent Mark Zuckerberg I'm in
well first of all I um
I do prefer nogi or Gigi Jiu Jitsu so
ghee is this outfit you wear that uh is
maybe mimics clothing so you can choke
what's like a kimono it's like the
traditional martial arts or yeah
um
that you could choke people with yes
well it's got the lapels yes yeah
um so I like Jiu Jitsu I also really
like MMA and so I think nogi more
closely approximates MMA and I think my
style is
um is maybe a little closer to an MMA
style so like a lot of Jiu Jitsu players
are fine being on their back right and
obviously having a good guard is is a
critical part of of Jiu Jitsu but but in
MMA you don't want to be on your back
right because even if you have control
you're just taking punches while you're
on your back so
um so that's no good do you like being
on top my style is I'm probably more
pressure and
um and yeah and and I'd probably rather
be the top player but
um but I'm also smaller right I'm not
I'm not like a a heavyweight guy right
so from that perspective I think like
you know it's especially because you
know from doing a competition I'll
compete with people who are my size but
a lot of my friends are bigger than me
so
um so back takes probably pretty
important right because that's where you
have the most leverage Advantage right
where where
um you know people you know their arms
your arms are very weak behind you right
so
um so being able to get to the back and
and take that pretty important but I
don't know I feel like the right
strategy is to not be too committed to
any single submission but I said I don't
like hurting people so
um so I always think that chokes are are
a somewhat more human way to go than
than joint locks yeah and it's more
about control it's less Dynamic so
you're basically like a Habib numbering
a Madoff type of fighter so let's go
yeah back take to a rear naked choke I
think it's like the clean the clean way
to go straightforward answer right there